kylie jenner lip syncs to travis scott's
track on tick tock
kylie
baby number two
congratulations thank you
and says she's starting to feel like
herself again after welcoming baby
number two dude i'm getting my
personality back then the 24 year old
reality star shared this sultry clip on
the app thursday laying in bed singing
along to a remix of her man song
goosebumps
[Music]
back in february kai and trav welcomed
their second child together a son whose
name they have yet to reveal
and on thursday the beauty mogul gave
fans a little insight into her
postpartum struggles
dude i'm getting my personality back
though like i'm feeling like myself
again yeah i really was not myself
she captioned the clip quote when your
postpartum hormones start to level out i
really was not myself
and if that sounds familiar it's because
it's kylie lip dubbing kylie yeah that's
a clip from her spin-off reality series
life of kylie dude i'm getting my
personality back though like i'm feeling
like myself again yeah i really was not
myself
but this isn't the first time kylie who
is also a mom to a four-year-old
daughter stormy has been candid about
life after pregnancy
i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy
it's not been easy it's very hard this
experience for me personally has been a
little harder than with my daughter it's
not easy mentally
physically
spiritually kylie kept it real with her
fans on instagram back in march hoping
to encourage other moms who might be
dealing with the same issues
it's okay
not to be okay once i
realized that i was putting some
pressure on myself and i just keep
reminding myself i made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy
and we have to stop putting pressure on
ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
after
after birth so yeah
just sending some love
the kylie cosmetics founder recently
revealed that she gained 60 pounds
during her pregnancy and is now down 40
revealing her strategy on instagram
quote just trying to be healthy and
patient walking pilates is my favorite
combo deep down like i would love my
true fans to know
like all my personal stuff and while
kylie has been sharing more of her life
after baby number two's arrival she has
yet to share any pics of her little one
as for his name well it was initially
revealed as wolf but the couple later
announced they changed their minds
wolf was never on our list okay um
it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf
i just wasn't him
but kylie told et last month she and
travis were closing in on a new moniker
we have some um
we have some really strong options but
we haven't officially changed we have
some placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure
[Music]
you